there's always that one jamaican there
that never gets a haircut he just walks
in and just sits down eats food
he's yam and chicken feet and just
speaks
[Music]
while going guys girls what are you
saying
as you can see we're in a completely
different
abode today yeah we've come up today
we've come up here we've come up in the
space today you might recognize that you
might recognize the logo young jim shark
yeah man so jim shot reached out and
they said they need like the whammist
the women's content creator is going
so we fought arms curly on to the death
yeah
and we won we won so here we are
um so yeah guys we're doing a special
episode for gymshark today so we hope
you enjoy it thanks uh what is this app
201 201 that's come a long way 201
episodes bro yeah man so if you guys
missed episode 200 because you're not on
patreon so get over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs come on man
three pound a month
run the p you know you know what it is
there he goes three years of content on
there binge worthy juicy
secret codes
cult culture facts white robes over on
patreon guys so yeah pause the episode
quickly run it over there and then come
back and enjoy the rest um so
today we are in
a nice little place in london called
shoreditch
and we're like a juicy um
barbershop yeah mum like a pop-up
barbershop yeah like a painting
barbershop they've done it up they've
kitted it up they've really kicked it up
yeah um
i was gonna get a line up myself but i
was terrified i was thinking about
getting a shapey butt as well yeah and
the thing is i already know it's going
to be longer than what i would normally
get but it's just but cheating on your
barber it's like a it's like a it's a
faux pas
i was not expecting you to say that yeah
it's yeah it's just something you don't
do mum it's certainly you don't do
there's a code of ethics in the world
yes there is and like experiment in
hitting the streets with your haircut
yeah that's that's her behavior
yeah total behavior you've got you've
got a bond of your barbecue
yeah you got it he's got a he's got a
trust that the secrets you're
sharing are his secrets and he's only
yeah that's his source you can't just be
running running that to anyone
um and he needs to know that yeah he's
his clientele yeah yeah his fingers are
the only ones in your mouth
oh jesus bro yeah um
but tick-tock is is killing barber
barber life at the minute why because
these man trying to show out the other
day i went to mine
he sprayed my face right here he put his
phone on
oh when they do the spray spray
he's like yeah let me do a tick tock and
i'm like i'd rather you didn't he said
yeah
saw my lips he was doing like nine
different barber pranks
in one video
on you on me and you just stood there
i had no choice because you'd only done
you know this is how they get you you
know when they do the skin fade before
they do anything else so you've got two
levels so you have no choice but to just
sit there and firm whatever they're
gonna do to you
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah bulk up bro yeah oh wow the
other week um i let homeboy put a ticket
on my car just because i was really i
wasn't wanting to get up and yeah yeah i
think you told me about that yeah it's
happened multiple times yeah yeah you've
definitely talked about one time that
happened yeah because once you've got
that that skin and the three on top and
nothing in between you can't i'm not
going anywhere with the chair yeah you
can't leave the chairs at barista keep
my cape on i'm not going anywhere run me
the ticket and keep the k-pod yeah yeah
um
but
since we were here i was actually
thinking like um
about
what it would be like because obviously
you i spoke about the drama of my bob's
yes forever yes you have them the
difference between going to a black
barber and a white barber must be like
i don't know like prison and reform
and we just sit there and take it in it
i always wonder what would you call it
you said it yesterday tony a guy
a young tony guy my brother-in-law i
think this was this was probably
six seven years ago
um
he had he'd come from nigeria so he was
i don't
so he was back and forth from nigeria so
he had no like specific i'm sorry stop
i'm swiping your brows bro you're you're
dripping
the lights the change
it's affecting me in many ways than one
wipe your brow please my brow you know
back to my brother-in-law so he he was
um he didn't have a specific barber
he came from nigeria yeah he came from
that he was like two and throw two in
front he didn't have a specific barber i
was like i'll go to my one called
celino's but this is before i even spoke
to him about it and then it was like i
went to one in rumford called tony and
guys
and i was like what you went where
he said it was [ __ ] and they charged you
45 pounds
i was like why can't you ask me bro why
don't you ask my sister what did they do
to him i have because what's he what
kind of hair has he got he's got
probably like now he's probably got one
all over i think oh but i think then he
wanted it's exactly the same thing
either one all over a fade and they said
he charged him 45 pounds and it was for
a trip and he said it was absolutely
horrific
they would i reckon they offer him
champagne in it before before he looked
at facebook he had a warm towel around
his neck before everything he just
thought this is how they do it over here
yeah he went to one called totally a guy
i had my burst out laughing
jesus that's funny bro i'm actually
sweating but yeah he had the before the
the actual trim itself he had the best
experience
i know i know he's got yeah yeah yeah he
was allowed to play on card
his appointment was on time he's never
played on card in a barbershop
yeah it's not possible yeah the black
bars is not funny they don't let it
happen yeah yeah yeah i need yeah there
was no supermart in there
but in my barber there's he's got a
fridge yeah it's got random [ __ ] in
there yeah the drinks don't make it he
hasn't got water in there yeah he's got
capricorn yeah he's got superman
yeah yeah he's got bigger and he's got
uh grenade protein shakes that's an
array bro and he just keeps beard oil in
there and [ __ ] in the fridge
he keeps he doesn't want a beer bomb in
there it's a shambles bro
yeah the appointments are always late ah
but you have to firm it in it in fact
you've got no choice
you go to you go to a black barber if
your appointment's at 12 you're not
sitting down to at least 12 45.
that's a fact
i'm not gonna lie if he's if he's even
there
your barber has mugged you off too many
45 minutes oh yeah rags because i
remember one time we sat in there
and i was like bro like what is this
like it's 45 minutes behind like because
what he does is if you book an
appointment
if you book an appointment
um
that's your appointment slot fax but
obviously that means you're you're
you're you're jumping queue so his thing
is that's five pound more so it's like
15 pound for a trim yeah or 20 pounds
for an appointment trim whatever yeah so
i got in there 45 minutes late
and i said i'm not paying you the extra
five pounds because this is a joke okay
a man said you are
because
there's three men waiting behind you
so if you weren't jumping queue then
you'll be here for three hours you're
gonna run me the five pounds i was
fuming the same thing like i said he'd
already done the skin bit
so there's nothing you can do there's
nothing you can say in hot seat yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
on top and skin around the sides so if
you if you pipe up you don't know what's
going to happen to you facts yeah yeah
your life is literally in his hands
your life is literally in his hands yeah
it's a scary thought but yeah i reckon
tony a guy would never they'd never do
you like that tony i can never even i
would have loved to have seen the how
the transaction played out yeah yeah
yeah and the the tony and guy bar were
like
just walk in and i just want a haircut
what do you want mate um can i get one
all over a fade yeah man sit down sit
down how much does it cost um probably
around 45. i would get up and leave i
probably i would have a heart attack on
the spot 45 pounds i couldn't pay that
well shake
i could have paid yeah but they would
have offered him apple pay
they probably would have done a planner
thing three installments over three
months
fifteen fifteen fifty
lana
yeah they would have patted him nicely
oh yeah there's no getting out there i
would love it i would love to be able to
go in there because these men i go in
there and then they're just buying
bottles of sprite of crackheads and
stuff that's what goes on in barbecue
black barber's bro do you ever see that
they're saying that again the crackers
come in and just try and sell you
aftershave and [ __ ] do they not do that
you'll bother now they must because you
live in manchester they're my mother's
lifetime yeah they do you're just not in
there these times bro they do they do
they do they do they do no no no
so you
savage
some head some some dry shampoo and just
like anything that's a bottle of sprite
i promise you that doesn't work it
happens i promise you that's i
when i used to go to my barbers back in
i think it was in southeast london this
is when i was obviously living in london
um all they used to sell was all these
um
fake dvds uh what's it called um there's
pirate there's pirate movies yeah in the
sleeves yeah yeah oh those pocket
sleeves they'd always used to come in
with movies
they just come out yesterday i think how
is this even possible how are you man
allowing it to happen recorded on a
calculator yeah pirated on a [ __ ]
camera yeah so that that was the norm
that was the norm i remember obviously
i've told you this story before but i'll
say it again
same barber shop in um in southeast i
remember i was there and i was sleeping
it was my i think i was two
i had two people before me and my pops
gave me it was a fiber back then to cut
your hair a young five pounds cut your
hair now it's what you pay 25 i paid 25
at least
in birmingham we paid 25 standards yeah
um
sat there i was like i'm tired dropped
my head
had a five pound in my hand someone gave
me a young high five and swiped the five
pound from my hand
and i couldn't for some reason i was in
like a what's that sleep paralysis thing
i just couldn't wake you up yeah
sandman had you up bro couldn't wake up
woke up it was my turn my pops was like
where's the five pound i gave you fam i
was stammering i didn't know what to
tell him because someone didn't know he
gave him my hand and he knows he gave it
to me so how can i sit there and say i
think someone stole it
we're all in the shop together yeah yeah
yeah
and you can't yeah you can't just accuse
people in a shop you can't just accuse
people in there ten yeah yeah yeah these
are big boy adults accusing man of
stealing my firepower yeah yeah it gets
heated
i've seen fam i've seen everything in a
barber shop i've seen drug exchanges
i've seen i've seen everything in there
bro i was in there the other day and my
brother was chatting to someone who's in
prison now
i think because he's a loud speaker
speaker and then that man was like he
said the thing like would you want to
accept the charges for the call i'm
speaking is that real is
about trims in prison why because these
men are a cultural hub oh wow that's
what happens when you're obama bro you
you meet man because i've been going to
my boss since i was 14. yeah i remember
you saying and the barber i left him for
was a raging alcoholic but i stuck with
him for too long in it until he just
stopped showing up
i went to he got it but he had the he
was the freshest bubble when it comes to
when you're like are you and you used to
be patterns in that yes he could do the
best patterns bro nike's the swirl
yeah like your head back would just be a
banksy piece
your head back would be a bangs yeah it
was lit but he was he was yeah he was a
raging alcoholic yesterday because my
mom used to make me call him a minute i
think i've told him
and i'll use that you're watching
exactly i used to have so much anxiety
because he'd be like i'll call him into
that who's this he's so aggressive and
i'm like hello
his name was paul lowe is that paul i
think he listens to us now actually is
this paul yeah who's this it's um
it's james
fam
james stone can usually get my hair on a
wednesday at four
bro yeah what have you got appointment
thing yeah and then
you didn't know where you were going to
show up
he would text you his location his
location i'm telling you humble was a
raging alcoholic but when i said this is
barbara codges bro he just where i'm at
is where you're getting your haircut no
sometimes i'll go to his yard sometimes
he'd be working in a respectable shop
sometimes
one time he was in a leisure center he
just booked out a sports hall like a
badminton court thing and he was just
streaming
i swear
[Laughter]
family was and there was just guinness
camps everywhere he was cheering me what
chair he just used like a school chair
in it oh you're a bro but you're not
allowed to ask questions
this is how it went do you want your
haircut or not
bad nice and cool with guinness
yeah the area where i live called rock
street that's where all the parties used
to be he's just in there
just post shrubs oh my goodness just
waiting to trim my nose just shut
cutting hair that's that's embarrassing
so yeah so then yeah when i left him to
go to new barber i thought everything
was going to change because i was
thought it can't get worse he can't get
worse yeah he's in he's in the shop he's
going to stay in the shop the shop yeah
yeah my barber now from i'll book an
appointment and he'll text me on the day
saying i'm in zanzibar i forgot to block
out my calendar go see donny in chair
too that's a piss take bro that's a piss
take
i've got events i've got stuff to do i'm
not just anyone anymore we're up in
gymshark barbershop you know what i mean
i need trims on the day i can't have
this i just can't so yeah it is
it is what it is that's that's poor man
but there is like at the same time you
you firm it because that's like that's
your boy you have to yeah yeah that's
your boy that's why like cheating on is
it is it's a sin but i remember when i
first moved to manny
i was going to so i was doing my due
diligence obviously i didn't know anyone
in my i didn't know which barbershop to
go to and i think i was to and fro
london for like the first month just
getting trims no just for i was going
down to my family blah blah blah for the
first month i moved to manny i moved to
many 2017.
um so for the first month i think i got
two trims in london in my yeah my normal
barber celino's yeah
you
know
was it g yeah yeah yeah
came up to manny now and i was i lived
in moss side moss area so i was walking
around walking around yeah you lived in
[ __ ] i lived in england oh yeah i went
to that barbados
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i was
walking around walking around because
it's there was a barber shop next to you
the big ass that i used to go to
and it was a jamaican barber i was
thinking cool just two seats i've seen a
lot of black people go in there i've
seen a couple trims yeah yeah right it
doesn't look that bad i'm walking now i
was like yo safe safe safe um i think i
spoke to the owner i can't remember his
name for the life of me
sat down i was like what do you need or
what do you want i was like normal skin
fade low skin fade please pattern me and
it was like i think 15 pound back then
or 12 pound back then yeah yeah so i got
the trim now and i was like
it's not as good as what my barber in
london did but i'm affirming yeah my
phone because i don't know anywhere else
this is a fundamental we can work up
from work up from here and i know it's
only going to get better
you know i know it's only going to get
better yeah yeah so back then i was
working in australasia in mani so i was
going and going and going i was thinking
my trim is not the best and there
weren't that many black people in
australasia at that time with fresh trim
so i was thinking
i don't even know where or who to speak
to about this you know i know i know i
can't confide in it
[Laughter]
i don't know just speak to
i'm sorry that's tweeting me i'm sorry
is it going going why not so um
obviously you remember a fella from uni
yes so his brother yeah i remember manny
at the time yeah and he worked in
australasia for a bit i think i i don't
know if i
[Music]
where did you get your trip from yeah
where the [ __ ] did you get your trip
from he's like oh one danny down in
print works i was like show me
[ __ ] show me yeah yeah yeah then
that's when i was when i was still
living in moscow but then i used to walk
about 20-25 minutes just to get my trim
from this other better
but there was a time where i was like
okay i need an emergency trim because i
think this was before you came up to see
me one day yeah yeah as we normally do
so i went to my man in moss side i was
like standard low cut low skin fade
rather blah blah blah blah he was kind
of cutting it kinda now and the breader
next to him
was always given fresh trims or fresher
trims than what my guy was doing but
because i was still so new into that
game i couldn't just be you can't just
dilly-dally you know also you can't
cement your position
exactly you can't exactly you need to
know you're a freak he needs to know
that you're free
yeah yeah
when i'm not your property but i also
didn't have the balls to be like you're
not cutting my hair today let homeboy
cut my hair yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is his shot yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i cut
he got he um he got my um he trimmed me
now and i was thinking
this could be one of the worst trims
he's ever given me
this literally could be one of the worst
shrimps he's ever given so he wasn't
even consistent he wasn't consistent
with it because sometimes it was this
this thing here sometimes it was so low
sometimes it was so high this time it
was so
high
it wasn't a skin fade yeah it was just
skin and hair
it was skin and hair
so i remember obviously
you messaged me saying oh you're outside
my thing obviously there was a massive
gate
so yeah i remember yeah i was running
back running back and i was saying bro
mama's got me looking like a suffer
power in this [ __ ]
i remember you said bro
funniest thing i've ever heard it was
all skin and just a layer of hair fam i
couldn't believe it
i never went back
i never went back james i was walking 20
25 minutes the other day
i couldn't believe it i remember this is
actually how i know what i was saying
earlier as facts because i remember when
i went to get my hair cut in manchester
yeah at your donny before ibiza in the
end
just put his bike on the side and was
like
who's getting fresh first trim of the
day gassing me up like oh you're getting
these fresh hands
that's like you're taking the piss out
of me like they haven't there's no
there's no apologies to it yeah they're
it's their shots yeah
let me pitch crypto to you that's that's
what we're doing today
but that's what that's that's the beauty
of barbers is like yeah because they go
through so many people on a daily basis
they'll pick up a convo with you yeah
that they didn't finish with next man it
doesn't matter
yeah yeah and it gives you a level of
security that you haven't experienced
before do you know what i mean
level of security because you'll just
sit down and think because i'm not a big
talker i don't talk to strangers like
that yeah so just sit down ask you what
you want telling me yeah yeah and it'll
start cutting and they'd just be like
ah bitcoin's crashed again and i'm
thinking ah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he'll just start
telling you about like how his baby mom
it's just it's just bleeding him dry do
you know what i mean it's just it's just
like i can't take it anymore and you're
thinking i don't know you i don't know
what we're talking about yeah stop stop
and then but he just he doesn't care if
you ask follow-up sorry yeah he's just
going again in the game you all talk to
the person behind you yeah and he's just
telling
what they have he's hustling
to let you know he's hustling and
pennies make the pounds yeah yeah this
is not my only gig yeah this is why i
was late because yeah yeah
yeah i've got i've got properties in
tanzania that no one knows about yet i'm
working on a block of flats this is not
it for me and he doesn't need to he
needs to let you i don't need to be here
i love i do it for the love of the game
and i want to be a part of my community
i'm just looking at him in the mirror
just bro cut my hair yeah
but that's when yeah that's how they
chirps you because then they get you
talking of course i was like yeah yeah
yeah
what are you doing
oh i just do this little
like podcast thing yeah yeah yeah what's
that then
oh it's just about yeah what do you mean
talk about how did you have fam half an
hour in
i'm screaming in there
i'm screaming about like
fasting ramadan stuff i don't know about
i'm just screaming about it and every
man's involved
there's always that one jamaican there
that never gets a haircut he just walks
in
chicken feet and just speaks
he just starts talking and he's invested
in every conversation
and chicken feet
he's always sucking his fingers bro he's
just in there and he
you've never seen him get a trip and he
might ask homeboy he'd be like
mid-trim he'll just tap your barbell on
everything blah blah that makes you just
line me up
he's leaning over you and his gristle's
just falling under the shoulder he's
like just do this local thing this
little thing here oh my gosh it's so
annoying but it's like
there's those are the only places that
you can be willing to wake up on a
saturday morning and spend three hours
sitting oh facts bro my pops used to go
to a barber shop called mirrors i think
this was in north london we used to live
in southeast and he wouldn't go there to
get a trim he would go there on the
weekend to chill
shut the [ __ ] up i would go there on the
bro that was his hub
again i'm investigating
like saturday and sunday i i went there
a couple times for a trim it was
literally
how can i explain it it was like um
it was like a group chat somewhere like
a live group chat that's what it was it
was it was their
space to just relaxing talking chilling
and it's just all the gangs it was all
the guys him and these boys and so many
views because i was there as well
sometimes but he would literally go
there every hour every saturday or every
sunday night it's like i'm just going to
mirrors i'll be back whenever
that's
and i didn't know it at the time because
i was obviously i was going to barbers
but i was going to barbers with my
parents yeah because they would take me
there so i wouldn't really engage in all
this conversation blah blah blah i
didn't know what the culture was like
but thinking back now i was thinking
yeah this is what these men do oh he
might go to barbers just to chill and
chinwag that's banging and he did that
for years bro really yes bro yeah
because one of his friends
owned that store and they've been boys
for ages so they used to go there that's
when you that's when you see the side of
your dad you've never seen before he's
just swearing he's just swearing
swearing and laughing and drinking
you hear a laugh that you've never heard
dad laugh before
you didn't know your dad could laugh
like that the funniest thing about it is
my dad is bold yeah so he never got
trims he always trimmed his own hair you
would skin his own head yeah so you he
would literally go there for bands oh
literally that was a tough man it was
that's actually cute it made me realize
yeah yeah some some men need that yeah
they need that culture when you see when
you see people like that especially like
your dad you realize
you don't love us though do you know
what i mean because the laugh they're
laughing it's not the life you like at
home when you're home you're always
vexed
so why are you laughing like this your
mom could never see him anymore i'm
surprised he let you come i really am
i'm not even joking i've got trims there
a couple times oh yeah yeah but i think
it was one of those ones where i would
get trims and then we'd dip cause he
would go there at like
11 o'clock like p.m oh shut up yeah bro
that was their heartburn i'm not i'm not
gassing bro swear yeah yeah he'd go
there at night come back in the morning
like early i was in the morning
that's that was their thing oh that's
mad that was their thing speaking of
trims i was thinking
i made me realize this when we started
going to the barber in burma so yeah
that's just full disclosure because i
don't think i ever i know i did i did
because when i was looking for a new
barber
when i quit i'm gonna quit homeboy yeah
i was looking for a birmingham barber
i've got so many recommendations yes and
obviously went to see homeboy uh i don't
give them the plug at stars stars
barbers
live the fade is not making sense a1
yeah yeah it blends bro it blends
differently
it looks like you know when you're art
class and you used to do the charcoal
thing and then the smudge
it runs like that and i was thinking
this thing making sense yeah and it
reminded me what i was thinking about
the other day do you remember when we
were growing up
when ludacris first cut his hair off yes
bro the lineup
ludicrous luna chris is in every barber
shop he's if his face is in the
barbershop it's not legit it's not legit
give me the number three but no one
could ever patent it like that yeah yeah
yeah we didn't know about this die in
the spray though cause thinking his
lineup is doesn't matter
it's geometric it's crispy yeah yeah
literally 90 degrees
literally 90 degrees did it make sense
blacker than night and 90 degrees and
the sideburn was just i was thinking bro
how who is luna chris's barber yeah who
is doing this magician yeah this
magician is [ __ ] magic
it's a witchcraft thing yeah it is it
was nuts is it but then to be first yeah
stars have been bleeding me up like that
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
shout out to stars one yeah
um
so what we were going to talk about a
little bit today
is um
the mental health aspect
of coming to your barber and having that
release like basically what your dad
said no you said it's actually it's
actually perfect that you said it's um
it was a group chat thing for him
because i've realized recently that the
more people i interact with like dudes
especially and actually girls i've
always i always assume that a girl's
group chat is just the littlest thing
going that's why i assume this one but
when we've been talking to people
recently it's not even it's not even
that it's kind of dead yeah yeah it's
just dick pics
it's just dick pics and abuse abusing oh
what should i wear for this day yeah
yesterday for that day yeah yeah yeah
there's no there's no heart to heart our
group chat is heart to heart
judgment freeze
yeah yeah yeah
bands on heart to heart yeah and
the occasional side boobs
yeah
but yeah it's it's it's banging in there
yeah um and i was thinking i actually
think like most people don't have it now
most people don't have that that level
of security that the judgment free time
because i've got close personal boys who
aren't in our friendship group
and they're just lighting me about [ __ ]
i mean when it comes to like girls or
like when you say lie to you like you
find out they're like yeah i find out
that they're lying so when it comes to
just like their relationship issues or
stuff like stuff that's happening in our
work or stuff like that they'll tell me
and they'll tell me like oh this is
annoying because of this or she's doing
that or like i've blocked her because of
x y and z and then you find out like
none of that was the case like you're
still chatting to this girl and she's
she's hurting you and you're not
confident
and i'm thinking what's going on
in it chat to me but
some people just need like a stranger to
talk to facts and like i was thinking
because of the barber thing it's
actually i've had conversations with my
barber that i'm so grateful that i had
with him and not anyone else yeah
because
i'm essentially paying him to be on my
team so when he gives you his honest
opinion and he's like now you're
actually a [ __ ] because of x y and
zed you take it you don't take it
personally you don't take the first
actual
you have to be telling me the truth if
you're not on my side yeah yeah so it is
like and they said he has he has no dogs
in this race he doesn't give a [ __ ]
because once i walk out the door he's
just going to chat to someone else so he
doesn't have there's no incentive for
him to feel one way make you feel one
way or the other he's just telling you
how he hears it and you're just saying
like how he sees it and it is
it is banging so obviously these guys
hit us with some stats about just like
how the percentage of people
that
will confess their
kind of situations and just confide in
barbies confide in barbers before they
confide in therapists friends this that
the other family whatever family yeah oh
family yeah i'm going to talk to my
mother nothing i don't chat to my mum
about anything you're gonna pay me to
talk to my mom about something that's on
my chest
that's on my chest
you couldn't pay me to get something out
of my chest to my mom why
because it's just
this actually oh perfect perfect example
why barbara's better than my mom okay
because i don't need these follow-ups
okay i want to say what i want to say
yeah yeah here's someone's opinion and
then take it and just get on okay i
don't want my mom texting me saying how
are you feeling this morning about how
we spoke about yesterday or the thanks
for telling me this i know it was tough
shut up i don't need don't embarrass me
shut up we didn't speak about anything
just shut the [ __ ] up so yeah the barber
thing is much better i've had a call of
a converse with my barber okay that's
why i let him abuse my head top after 14
years of this fair yeah and just rock up
when he wants and go on holiday when
he's off your life oh that's literally
half my life he's seen me from when i
used to rock up in school uniform oh wow
to when i'm having like
big time relationships
car yard career everything he's seen
everything oh wow he's actually mad and
i get my head like every week yeah just
every week for years and years and years
and years and years he sees everything
wow
yeah wow so then sometimes when he's
stretching my hairline so back that you
can't see it from the front you have to
sit there and firm it
because you're just like he's been
yeah we've been for a long time you've
known him longer that you've known me
yeah he's your boy literally i've been
longer than i've known you yeah he's
actually mad
but so yeah we did some
some due diligence now yes so we reached
out to people about stuff that they've
shared with strangers yeah yeah yeah um
as opposed to
sharing with their boys or their
partners yeah so what's something
personal you've not told your group chat
significant other but you've opened up
to a stranger about
and yeah some of them some of them are
tough bro and some of them are [ __ ]
hilarious
all right let's
let's take 10 minutes
get deep yeah personal and then let's
just yeah we'll run the joke after cool
all right cool cool first one i wrote
first of all yeah
what all right let's just do this what
when you read the serious ones yeah all
right first of all tell me when we're
gonna transition to the serious ones are
the funniest ones they're in a block
there's no separation so it's whether
you want to laugh or not it's up to you
that's not fair i'm going to tell you
when to laugh because you know which
ones are which
so i don't want to laugh and then you'll
be like nah that's actually why are you
laughing so serious right now yeah
yeah yeah and say how you say it normal
because i know how you like to dramatize
some stuff
don't emphasize anything just read it as
it said
all right cool
we'll just we'll talk about one of them
[ __ ] sake
this one is actually pretty peak
because i can imagine not imagine but we
can somewhat relate this to our
friendship group if if need be yeah
first guy said i have a crush on one of
my friend's fiances ah
that's very very very very tough bro bro
that's actually a confiding you can't
tell you can't tell anyone that anyone
about that
anyone so telling a complete stranger
i.e your barber you have to use that you
have to get off your chest that's really
neat yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that'll
put a burden on me every single day oh
fam as soon as he left that jay he was
10 kilos lighter thank you
thank you i needed to sell someone yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's nah bro
i could never imagine myself being
physically attracted and fancying your
fiance oh neither could i
like that would break me bro yeah yeah i
would break you
i'll break your nose
[Laughter]
oh that's tough yeah you can't just tell
anyone that you can't accept yourself a
[ __ ] movie what's um what's that that
british sometime that's on that movie
oh megan megan what is it
what's that christmas movie the romance
movie
love
love actually that's the thing i love
actually in it i don't remember one
brother yeah he's um he's a number of
his uh his brethren's girl okay and he
knocks on the door to send in a pamphlet
like like just you know the um the trend
where they're right sign
and then they drop the card
he writes up on the he's actually a
[ __ ] yeah he's supposed to be
romantic but
the logistics of it he's a waste man
okay he rocked up to their yard his boy
and the girl's yard with these these
these cute cards yeah and just basically
said fam i love you
i [ __ ] love you shut the video
shut the [ __ ] up
he's in the shower shut the [ __ ] up
and he's just dropping cue cards like
it's a ting but it can't be a thing come
outside real quick it's snowing out here
come lips me but shut up shut the [ __ ]
up they they made it seem romantic but
it's actually about a violation
he's definitely ops that's definite ops
yeah cool cool next one being gay as an
arab guy my family have no clue
that's it these actually aren't funny
it's tough i'm telling you that's tough
that's literally you can't tell your
family about stuff like that yeah that's
there's certain places that will stone
you to death if you're gay
facts bro
facts he's just holding it he's holding
it in
who can you tell but a stranger yeah you
have to tell you about because there's
no other option there's no other option
out of community thing yeah you're
getting on a bus to the shop yeah all
right you couldn't be in your vicinity
you couldn't get a five minutes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the bubble stone
bro
wow these are actually and man just sent
these in on instagram instagram brother
they really needed to get it off ah
that's
fam
i enjoy watching gay porn
we don't kink shame we never kink
who do you talk to about that i just
enjoy it he's enjoying it so he's not
confessing that he's not coming out or
anything like that i just like watching
watching gay porn and i don't know who
to talk about with this who would you
talk about who would you talk to about
it
you could never okay i was going to say
if you couldn't our group is tight
i think i'd rather tell all of you man
at the same time yeah yeah yeah they'll
just tell you
because i i wouldn't have to take that
information yeah yeah yeah
i would yeah your reaction will make me
want to drag your beard
because i'm coming to you with
confidence there's something that's
burdening me
yeah yeah
yeah that's actually tough i don't know
how i would communicate bro
facts
i'm doing it now yeah all right fam
facts talk to me big man thing i'm not
gay but
that's the thing i don't you can't even
premise this yeah i'm not good i
wouldn't even shut up
i'm not gay but shut up let me finish
the sentence i just love watching the
porn and i don't know what it is
bro we'd have to help me
how did this even start how did you
realize you how did you transition from
regular point to gay porn like it's just
found to be fair
let's step out no i'm not i'm not
robbing anymore
i'm not role playing anymore okay yeah
because we know where it's gonna go it's
just yeah
let's step outside of the situation for
a second i reckon yeah there's rabbit
holes on porn these days there's rabbit
holes you could easily just find
yourself
dilly-dallying in a
because
yeah all it is is just like
a [ __ ] party
it's your three thumbnails away from
this just guys in here because
yeah yeah
there's just guys in here now
and i didn't i don't know how we ended
up here do you know what i mean because
there's certain things there's just guys
in here the ratio is gonna go from
equals 50 50 to now there's three girls
and like seven dudes yeah and now
there's like six guys and one girl
and now there's just guys and i don't
know how we got here but because
the psychology behind it yeah i'm still
lost in this yeah yeah and now it's my
habit
so i'd need to tell i'd need to tell all
of you man all at once
yeah and then yeah but yeah please this
will be fun okay yeah read the next one
next
my husband and i are separated so my
husband and i have been separated for
three years we still live together
but he hasn't told anyone
he hasn't told anyone that he lives with
his wife yeah but they've been separated
for three years and he just lives in the
yard he lives in the yard because he
can't confide in anyone and say big man
i'm stuck here i'm stuck here
but i don't know what to do
three years of this three years and she
knows he hasn't told anybody she knows
he knows no she's not even on his team
anymore
she's telling everyone
how because if you don't tell him in the
first instance
if it's been more than a couple months
how do you broach a topic let alone
three years oh by the way lads he hasn't
got bedrooms at all what do you mean
they don't know he lives with his missus
no they know he lives with misses but he
didn't know oh they don't know he's
separated for three years
raw
okay now i'm with you oh
wow so they're just play
they're role-playing all the time for
three years three years she needs to
step up and tell him i'm not doing this
anymore no i'm gone yeah i'm gone i
don't care about you and your friends
that's your that's literally your
problem yeah yeah yeah i'm gone i can't
deal with this three years of it they
might as well just get back together
she's a trooper she is she's a keeper
they actually do live together they
still live together purely because he
doesn't he can't let anyone know he
can't tell assault he's not told us all
wow
that's tough bro these are literal
things you have to tell strangers
oh yeah right you have to tell strangers
yeah because you can't tell your boys
yeah yeah yeah strange is a it's a
judgment-free zone with you yeah oh rags
the barbershop will help you
the chicken feet brother be like what he
will drop
what did you say
what
you're just just
just rolling with me
just
running down his [ __ ]
what did you say
[Laughter]
out we need it for you come bro
i hate my girlfriend and i don't want to
be with her but i'm trapped as i've
moved into a flat four months ago
i hate her i hate my girlfriend so she
doesn't know that he hates her they're
just they're just doing the relationship
and they moved into a flat together four
months ago
and he's just stuck here at least to the
end of the first lease
it's a year minimum
he's got he's gone i hate her eight
months to go minimum yeah i couldn't i
hate her yeah 100 that's a what did you
say your dad's thing is called mirrors
mirrors yes
that's an 11 to 1am
nearest thing on a daily daily daily
basis he would need to get that off his
chest yeah every day
it's tough mum yeah
all right bro actually
this is actually everything what
that that one there yeah is a pen up
thing because it made me realize i was
gonna talk to you about it we haven't
had a chance to speak about it yet
slight digression and we'll get back to
this brent's album
brent's album is is everything i needed
brent we said this a lot months ago we
needed a bread album this summer and
he's absolutely delivered the one thing
i would say that i don't like he's got
way too many
interludes deleted everything i say the
album deleted every interlude i remember
you said you didn't listen to
intellectually yeah but it's sorry to
cut you off there's one interview that's
an actual song yeah i can't remember
which one it is but yeah there's so easy
i deleted the whole thing he's trying to
do role plays and everything yeah yeah
yeah he's toxic in there but he made me
realize you know addictions yes
um
that actually
that
addictions
is
what you get to when you hate your
misses can't leave the yard i can't talk
to anyone about it
because she's just in there
maybe it's the money yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah so um
you made me think about it literally
when you can't chat to anyone about
something and like a perfect example
you're living with your misses yeah
you can't get off your chest that you
[ __ ] hate her yeah you can't tell her
you hate her because you're stuck in
this yard until next year yeah you
haven't got any boys or family or anyone
to talk to
you haven't got relationship with your
barber you can just get it off your
chest yeah and she's there like fam
what is it with you like you you don't
chat to me you don't want to sleep in
the same bed with me like do you hate me
or something like what's wrong with you
yeah and she's like maybe like is it to
do with your childhood like is it to do
with like your work yeah and man's like
bro fam listen bro yeah maybe it's my
work maybe it's a love maybe it's a
drugs
the weed maybe it's the [ __ ]
i don't know why i'm here maybe it's all
the above
maybe i don't need a hug maybe i'm just
[ __ ] up
that's what he's getting all of your
chest yeah yeah he's vexed i want to
have more threesomes but you're so
territorial
i can't even kick it because you're
watching my stories though i got
something you seen and i got something
you don't need to know i've been given
more dick than a little
that's what i've been doing and i need
to get off my chest and i can't talk to
you about these kind of things that's
that's actually a track he he spoke his
heart he let it all out yeah yeah he let
it all out and i was thinking yeah he
hasn't got an outlet
he's
he's not
the man that need to come in this barber
shop i'm not the type of man that needs
to be listening to brent's album because
he's romanticizing depression
yeah that's romanticizing
his torment fuels him creatively yes yes
and then he just gets off on it he just
gets more money more women
and it just continues and more drugs it
just continues suspicious
and then he just grows his hair and
wears darker sunglasses and then manor
just like that's [ __ ] cool
yeah but are you all right are you right
yeah he's like yeah he's calm he loves
breaking hearts he does yeah he's like
he's what tobes would be
if tobes could express himself
creatively he would literally be back
he loves heartbreak he loves just
wallowing in in self-pity and drinking
himself to sleep
[ __ ] it out toby bum
right back to it
um so to recap what's something personal
you've not told your group chat
significant other but you've opened up
to a stranger about
so this guy wrote conflicted because all
my mates make fun of me for being a
virgin but i've slept with one of my
mate's girlfriends
family
he's he's
he's getting by like
every other day trims he's getting shape
ups every other day because he needs
something
he's in there in the mirror like this
brother keeps testing me he doesn't know
i was banging his mission
last week and you know what i keep
chatting [ __ ] oh how are you virgin yeah
yeah he's on about it
if only you knew keep chatting [ __ ] keep
chatting [ __ ] on fifa and see what
happens to you
it will slip oh yeah i will crumble the
bricks in your own yard
i'll take the carpet from beneath you
bro so keep trying [ __ ] yeah he has to
get it all out in the barbecue yeah
yeah just talcum powder just everywhere
vex yeah yeah he could that can never
leave his mouth oh fam this rolls right
into the next one coming to the
realization that i might be bi but i
don't know how they take it
this is all just
closets
it's confessions bro
i don't know how they take it just when
i thought i said all i can say my chick
on the side says she's got one on the
way these are my confessions
bro
i was like what are you saying then i
gathered
um i'm not [ __ ] yes bro i just don't
know how they're taking it i don't know
how they will take it oh this is talked
about their partner their partner or
their boys or whoever i don't know i
don't know how anyone's gonna take this
anyone's gonna take it [ __ ] sake yeah
carry on
this one jokes i always charge the boys
a little bit more when i book group
things i save the bag easy
nah i can never find that oh that's a
piss tank
nah bro you remember
you know what's funny
there's one thing
that i was actually reminiscing about
this the other day there's one thing
that happened when we were younger
when we were younger that's the kind of
thing that if you found out by yourself
you could never tell us but luckily we
were there to all find out at the same
time yeah yeah yeah yeah do you remember
when it was your birthday and we went
out in liverpool
and we've been out for many which one
one birthday you'll remember this
because we all gave you money for the
hotel
we all gave you [ __ ] money for this
hotel
bro and we rock up to this hotel and man
said yeah that'll be 300 400 pound
whatever it is and you were like in what
what i thought you might already i
thought you took the money already
i
and you turned to us and said fellas
they're telling me
that they didn't take the money last
week
i know so okay cool that's fine so so
where's the money we sent you fam i went
shopping you said i just thought i had
more money in my account than usual i
went shopping it's gone i've spent it i
forgot about that you could never find
that out
yeah yeah and then come and tell me
because i would have fought him in the
street
i was so
embarrassed but there was nothing else
tell you yeah yeah yeah i bailed my
sister on the spot oh no help me she had
to help you help me i wouldn't believe
anyone i need two bills now yeah oh my
sister's saved me a lot of times bro
yeah yeah i was right yeah my brother's
now my brother used to save me all the
time but my brother's temperamental
because he likes to teach me a lesson
when i don't know
i can't i can't have that when i was
younger when i just like pt and i was
broke yeah i was broke bro everybody
should be a lesson for every month if i
was behind or a client hadn't paid me on
time oh bellam blah blah i need like a
hundred pound till thursday okay and
here black bet scent and i got so
comfortable with it now once i bailed
him on i was in tesco
with a trolley i failed him i said bro
i'm really sorry to do this again i need
a hundred pound till tomorrow yeah man
said you know what no
he said james you need to get your [ __ ]
together no i said i was with
[Laughter]
why are you doing this why are you doing
this right now please
i have i have groceries in it
he said i'm not doing it figure it out
you're a grown man no he never i
promised you he did oh god no i'd have a
heart attack oh i had to just push the
trolley and just walk out no yeah just
dash the trolley and i'll free and just
[ __ ] up i was livid you know what
james no not today yeah he had he'd had
it enough but he didn't warn me that he
was anywhere near his limit
i just thought we had like a transaction
a relationship yeah yeah
you needed it i need it now
matt said you know what no no this is
the last straw like i'm an addict like
i'm not funding this anymore
you're in blood yeah yeah oh yeah he
actually treated you like an addict yeah
you needed a a yeah yeah
yeah yeah you can't do this anymore oh
my gosh that's hilarious all right um
moving on
family
after a breakup i once sang hero by
enrique and glaziers outside her window
no this is literally love actually bro
what
and you can't tell anyone this
who would who would i tell i would never
tell you man i did that
i would never tell you man i would love
you
i couldn't i wouldn't it would mean the
world to our friendship if you could i'm
not gonna lie to you if there's anything
that now that we're here yeah yeah if
there's any i mean like right now if
there's anything you want to tell me
just give up yeah tell me now nothing
like that has ever happened and i hope
hero is that what's that one i can be
your hero baby
baby i can take away the pain
you
wow
thing is yeah this was this was pre-ick
in it oh rags rags that couldn't happen
yeah
[Music]
absolutely slaughtered this is before
women had the options that they have
today this is proof it has to be
pre-social media pre-social pre what's
up all of that yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're like this ice cube if it's not
yeah everyone went the same school down
yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh i used to regularly see escorts
because my chat was dead i told the
group chat that my body count was seven
but he was just banging escorts
he didn't because he had not yeah
he physically could have chirps of soul
to save his life
man was just paying for it
wow
paying for it
but wow that's a confession i never
thought i'd hear fam i never thought i'd
read that
who can you actually tell about that
even telling the barber is a bit like
risque bro
imagine if i just confided in you with
that
i wouldn't know what to believe because
you shared stories with me james yeah i
don't know what to believe it's all
fabrication
everybody i have is
was was funded it was for everybody
i wouldn't know what to believe james
yeah no no you couldn't you couldn't you
couldn't open up to me what 15 years
later say bro yeah i paid for it all yes
i was chatting [ __ ] the whole time
please still be my boy please
yeah it's a barber take
off ends barbara as well yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
home visits it's not just not above a
shop chat that's yeah
i don't love my girlfriend but she's
introduced me to her family so i feel
stuck
i've been there have you i've been there
when i used to date that religious girl
and we were up in the air saying grace
and all sorts
say grace grace yeah yeah fam when i
dumped her i was
it was long because i used to see her
funny story i used to see her dad
literally in the barbers every saturday
really he just yeah he'd always go the
same time i went oh so i i stayed with
her literally like six months longer
than i wanted to because i think i can't
deal with this anxiety yeah yeah because
if i dump her
she's just side is a different now i
need to find a new barbados it's not
worth it yeah i'd rather like be unhappy
in my relationship but i'm happy with my
barber
i'd rather have a buff trim and be
depressed then
like yeah be happy and fulfilled
in a new relationship
and they'd have to find a new bible yeah
that's a long that's like
i've never i don't think i've ever been
in a situation where i've met someone's
family and i felt like it's wrong or
it's been too early like obviously i'm
not we've been i'm not with them now but
i've never been in a situation where
like yeah i think this is moving a bit
too fast fam do you remember our we've
got boy i won't explain his name he was
dating a girl
introduced her to his mom
and then dumped it like the day or the
day after fam i couldn't believe that's
a good reason
i couldn't i mean this was we were young
yeah yeah yeah it was a good 10 11 years
ago yeah yeah i couldn't believe the
savagery took her to meet his mom and
then the next day said you know what i'm
really not feeling yeah i don't know why
i introduced you
i generally don't know why i introduced
it to her she was about you i thought
two two two
we wasted everyone's time
but you i need you to come and get your
cream and your and your ointments like
because yeah yes
gal
i'm sorry you met my mum yesterday but
get out
i couldn't believe it yeah yeah so i can
see why anyone with a half a soul would
feel stuck after you've met the family
yeah because you can't do that to people
that was his fault man i was yeah my mom
she hasn't but my mum's met people yeah
yeah yes and i've again i've broken up
with people and told them same thing
i've broken up with girls
who have like
interaction with my mum yes and told her
like
if you see my mum do not tell her that i
dumped you because i can't be bothered
for it bro oh that's long i can't i'm
just
you just start showing up at the house
less that's how this is gonna end yeah
yeah she's just gonna see you less and
less frequently she's like oh where's um
where's such-and-such and i'm like i
don't [ __ ] know doing a thing in it
my mum all the time like are you two all
right and i'm like yeah my sharp why are
you asking me these silly little
questions you're all right you're all
right yeah man we're blessed and she
will see her ever again oh and then
i expect my mom to take priority and
yeah yeah it's done don't ask me about
it she gets it yeah you're her son yeah
it's a rap be on my side and understand
that we're not together let it be yeah
yeah silly questions about where's my
girl
don't ask me silly questions facts yeah
let me grieve
oh fam welcome i used to play mummy and
daddy with my neighbor when i was six
he was daddy i was mommy
really when i was six
and this is something obviously this is
something that's burdened in them and
they can't tell anyone about it i think
it's more better than him because he was
the mummy yeah i played mummy i played
mummy
with my neighbor
that's random that is random not being
dreaded when i was six i was timid bro
someone would easily finesse me to be a
mummy easily bro it wasn't my neighbors
and they were just a brute and i'm out
here trying to play beyblades or
whatever you gear cards yeah and i said
let's play mommy daddy and i'm like
what's that yeah well we've got these
dolls we've got these things yeah one of
us has to be the mom once dad like okay
you'd be mom
now i want to be like yeah i'd rather be
dead man
it's my yard and my dolls so you're
gonna be mummy
dolls
yeah we're going to do
yeah religious gender roles there's none
of this new age thing yeah your mummy so
it's a nappy and kitchen thing
they would finesse you yeah they would
have finessed me as well i'm not gonna
lie they would have finessed me as well
so a girl sent this in on behalf of her
guy or ex-guy oh dear
my ex had a foot fetish and would take
photos of girl's feet in public and keep
them for his wank bank
and she knew this she knew this
i need to know the layers behind this
ham i'm just it sounds like she needs to
confess this to someone
because he clearly doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah
he's taking pictures of feet in public
he doesn't give a [ __ ] she's this is
secondhand secondhand embarrassment for
her
because she needs to tell she can't tell
a group chat
she can never tell her yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
taking pictures of next galley
that's actually not even funny that's
actually really harsh
it's tragic
oh i know that's actually dressing me
feel bad because she needs to tell
someone she can't tell she can't tell us
she can't tell her hairdressers either
she could tell us some random dudes on
instagram and that's it
just to get out of her chest like my
boyfriend used to just take people's
feet
and just take a picture of people's feet
on the street on this channel and i was
with i was there i was with i was just
watching him do it
yeah
and he had it down to an r yeah if
anything zoom and i don't respect the
craft because he'd be there just just
portray that portrait
yeah the lighting was it was amazing
it's oh
that's that's peak that's peak my
partner has cheated on me she doesn't
know that i know i have the evidence in
case i need it
i think that's
see there's there's there's nothing in
this world that if i found out my girl
sheena i'm not holding that in yeah he
needs a later date he needs one of them
things where like they sit in the chair
and then he he's got an ego about it
yeah and then the barber just gives you
the the traps a little squeeze and black
it's all right
and just he just cries yeah he breaks
down
it's all right it's all right
stop being proud bro what's this
evidence thing
what's all this evidence chat leave
leave her
evidently
literally for what what's his conniving
chat it's too much man it's too much
anyway hmm
you're not gonna like this one oh if i'm
in what sense but there's just too much
of this sexual yeah i don't want to hear
this skip to the next one i don't want
to hear it anymore i'm being serious
i'll listen to it another day okay cool
when i was around 10 i bought thongs for
my mom but i never gave them to her i
wore them instead
that's not even funny
that's not even funny paraded around the
yard in mom's house
thongs from my mom just never gave me i
just never gave it to her
i wore them instead brother
[Laughter]
oh that's so dread
it's just for everyone involved
wow that one actually made me sweat [ __ ]
you now
[Laughter]
[Music]
fam
there's nothing on this world that would
make you forget this one
if this was your in your if you were in
this situation whilst my dad was drunk
he told me that he never wanted me and
that i was an accident
that's gonna stick with fam there are
things i've seen
my parents or family do when i was like
in year eight and i remember till this
day
yeah yeah
yeah yeah you can't have your dad chat
to you like that i used to say that to
my brother for banter when we were kids
yeah sibling banter yeah yeah sibling
parent can you never tell
fam to be fair
do you know when you were you and you
actually didn't know what accident meant
you used to just say it to each other
like you're like five yeah and i'm like
ah you're an accident someone little
brother you're an accident yeah yeah
yeah and the motherboard was like now
you had an accident and then i remember
one day my mom was like to be fair if
anyone was an accident it was you james
and i was like i don't know what that
means but i'm heartbroken i've never
said that
she did
why was she saying i don't know she's
just comfort in in her four walls in it
this is she pays the mortgage in this
yeah
she would say just say what she wants
yeah yeah yeah i still don't know
accident you're here and you're eating
so sharp
but i didn't know what i meant and it's
only now that i'm actually grown and i'm
like
because you actually know what
logistically that means
let's not say it but we all know what
actually that means birds and bees stuff
we all know what that means
it's long that's a long bro to be fair
back on the sibling chat i always used
to say to my sister there's no way
you're related to me
because i look like my dad oh i'm the
spitz of my partner yeah everyone tells
me that everyone that seems like you're
a carbon cop you're a carbon copy and my
mom's my mum i think i've got similar
features from my mom like her nose and
blah blah blah my sister doesn't look
like her she doesn't like anyone she
doesn't like anyone i'm thinking bro
you're adopted yeah i don't know where i
don't know why i don't know where why
are you here you're not from here you're
not from this you're not a dollar dude
like you're not part of this surname
so
bro yeah
yeah investigate yeah you do your due
diligence and run it back yeah because
this is all on you yeah bro it's it's
like my mom hit me with that accent
thing and i was just like
my jaw would have dropped i'm happy i
didn't know what that meant oh because
what you're telling me
is you and my father were just messing
around and that he wasn't even serious
yeah you remember just young and in love
that's what you're telling me there was
no preparation for this
but yeah hey ho that's pete game is the
game the game really is the game i egg
farted on a chick's face that was giving
me head i still put up a valiant effort
egg fired bro for [ __ ] sake
i can't even lie that's making me feel
like the figures the fact that i know he
could never tell anyone but she's told
everyone yeah right but
she's told everyone in a sense that
she's obviously slated him probably said
he's dick small as well yeah yeah
everything yeah he's useless this
[ __ ] stinks yeah
he's dead he said he stinks yeah don't
go there
that's the only way to get out of here
yeah because she could never tell her
friends that i was giving him
and he finally egg farted farted
exactly yeah she needs to yeah
regardless of what action she decided to
take from there
as far as the group chat knows he's gone
he's gone yeah
right
this one is so
because i told you i found this one last
night yeah you did yeah
yeah it's crazy okay i'm involved all
right cool so am i the [ __ ] right
so hey guys love the pod
um i've got a miley [ __ ]
i slept with this girl i used to work
with last week and i've had a crush on
her for time yeah i don't know what
that's like bro i've had a question of a
time oh i know what else
he's oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
a work relationship and a holiday
relationship will will send you i've
been there but anyway yeah you [ __ ]
have been there i've been there you [ __ ]
where you eat bro
carry on
carry the [ __ ] on it was good uh and she
wants to meet again but here's the
sticky thing
she shaved her head
found that she's shaved her head since
we slept together she did it to raise
money for charity okay so it's mad
i said obviously it's impressive and
it's admirable yeah i'm just not into
her anymore
i'm just not i'm just not into her
anymore that would have been a shell
shock for him
an absolute shell shock for him the next
day he
you know he just hit his knees and said
why can't i be happy
he felt his jesus said why don't i
deserve it just like everyone else
why would you do this to me
oh god
i'm just not into her anymore yeah uh
we'd agreed it was only ever gonna be a
casual thing okay so how do i end it
without just ghosting her and without
being that [ __ ] but still being
honest and they work together they work
together they slept together once she
said it's just a friends with benefits
thing it was like it could it's mutually
beneficial you like me i like you yeah
it's all good they slept together one
time he's gasped
and since then she's rocked up to work
and the head is bald
and he can't say anything because it's
just it's charitable yeah yeah [ __ ]
she's just getting high fives
and he's being i got i i get it i i
definitely get it yeah yeah i get it
yeah yeah
but
i'm just not horny
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i don't know how
to express this to her yeah yeah like
charitable donations don't raise my
blood pressure you know what i mean and
that's all good for the community but it
does nothing for me and then literally
i know i sound like a [ __ ] but this
is just how i feel
yeah he doesn't know who to talk to
about this
[ __ ]
i mean it
when you're not sexually attracted to
someone anymore it's tough
and her hair's not going to grow
overnight oh and it's not it's not it
probably looks better now than it's
going to look in like a month's time
because when it's like this long
it is on an 11 thing yeah
you know what i mean on a stranger
things too
yeah that's not yeah that's not the
romance i was thinking of you know
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and yeah
i don't know i don't the thing is i
don't know because some girls do look
nice with short hair yeah really nice
with short hair that's irrelevant to him
i know [ __ ]
it's shaved bro it's not yeah it's done
yeah
and i don't think it was that was
professionally done it was probably on a
tick tock live or something
yeah true to raise them a bit more money
bro yeah facts oh my god it's probably
patchy and everything oh my god um
what does he say to her
he needs to just come with chess he has
to yeah there's no way he's not asking
you you just have to own it
props first and foremost yeah props i
love what you're doing i love the cause
i can never do what you do
i rate you highly yeah but
yeah yeah yeah the passion we had last
week yeah it was gonna stay yeah in the
past
it's gonna have to stay in the past
because i've liked you for six months
yeah and it turns out it was just your
follicles i was into
and i didn't know that we how could we
ever know how would we ever know because
there was no way i would have told you
oh big man shaving head just so i know i
like you for who you are
you know what i mean i clearly don't
like you for you
i like you for your aesthetic
and your aesthetics only yeah yeah yeah
so
that being said
i might have to change
you know what he needs to do he needs to
do the [ __ ] that women do he he needs to
sit down i have a few drinks and be like
babe random
would you still [ __ ] me if i was a woman
i was a worm oh would you still buy me
another one yeah yeah yeah i'd be like
obviously not you're a woman yeah
cool
i wouldn't bang you if you were a worm
either
and
i think it's
do you know what it is about worms i
really don't like they're just so
hairless it doesn't make sense do you
understand where i come from yeah do you
understand where i'm coming from there's
just no hair like you should set up yeah
what are you talking about how can you
be an organism without hair doesn't make
sense to me
just she
keeps looking up at me
i can't remain icon yeah it just doesn't
do it for me worms don't do it for me do
you understand what i'm saying
i'll be like
no explain yourself
i don't really understand what you're
trying to tell me james
say it with yours say what you want to
say
because all this worm chat doesn't make
sense to me
all right cool when i was growing up
to the park when i was growing up we had
a tradition with the mandem and it's
strictly for the mandate yeah so you
can't romanticize it okay when you get a
fresh trim yeah your boy will smack the
back of your head and there will be dust
that will leave sweat and dust would
leave your head back thanks
and every time i see a ballet it just
reminds me of those days it's torment
for me yeah yeah yeah yeah you've done
that
for you but you've done it to me
it's on a pedi
[Music]
so yeah all the good you're doing
in rwanda
is negative that you're doing to me
so i think it's best if we remain
breached
yeah because
i'll if you want me to give you like a
head back smack like we can do that but
that's we're boys
we're literally yeah we're we're
bedrooms now and that's fine
and this has to be fine
because he's literally not he's doing
nothing for me yeah
yeah there's no choice we have to be
boys because it's doing nothing for me
yeah
i'm just not about it
and it's going to get worse from here
yeah because when you start having to
put like the little bobby pins and thing
in there
when they do the little part in like
this
and they have to comb it over with like
a pot of gel to get this little thing
here it's worse and worse yeah yeah it's
going to get worse and worse and worse
and worse
and you're going to be more and more
friends yeah as the time time goes on
you're more and more friendly yeah yeah
and i would expect the same treatment
i would expect the same treatment yeah
this isn't a one-way thing i don't want
no lovey-dovey anymore yeah if i decide
to shave my eyebrows for
world peace so whatever we're doing i
would expect you to look at me sideways
and be like i can't sleep yeah you chose
celibacy for hunger and that and that's
noble that's fine but we also have to do
the celibacy thing because that's the
path you've chosen so yes
yeah you've chosen to help people at the
cost of helping your love life yeah and
that's very noble so let's do it yeah
let's action that
all right um but anyway guys let's wrap
it there um thank you so much for today
yeah
props to uh jim sharp for setting this
up and having us over it's been
wonderful uh we'll put all the
information in the bio but
love love
[Music]